two nights one soul siegmeyer and secret
of catarina the nights of dark souls
stand as symbols of their homelands for
instance from Oscar and solare we sense
the valiant doom of astora from Oswald
and Lautrec the grim sects of Korean
look to Petrus to glimpse the hypocrisy
of thorolund or to the lothric Knights
for their motif of self-sacrifice but if
I ask you to imagine Katarina
you should think fondly of the place for
Katarina is a land of alcohol and
rejoicing and it's Knights a jovial and
brave like its neighbors Katarina is
surely crippled by the undead curse
which dooms the afflicted to endless
life and to a hollow fate but for all of
its horrors and death affords certain
opportunities some become motivated to
seek out ancient arts or to indulge
absurd obsessions it's no longer
unreasonable to think you could reach
the lands of the gods
war trigger ancient prophecies your
morals become challenged in the face of
eternity and it's likely the ancient
gods themselves who left you to this
fate but to sigmah his curse meant one
simple thing adventure and one by one
they all burn the limits of the flesh
the limits of want and while all of them
hollow in the end his stories remain
to be undead is to lose yourself and an
undead who loses everything becomes
hollow rare is the site of human in
Lordran for Sieglinde only has one life
to lose despite this she not only
travels halfway across the world to get
here but also manages to traverse the
length of Lordran itself making her an
ore inspiring night really Oh have you
seen my father you wouldn't miss him a
suit of armor just like mine thank
goodness I knew he was here somewhere
woven now I must find him thanks again
truly she's a small part of the life
that seek Maya left behind but an
undead's memories fade quickly with the
oldest going first
my daughter risk life and limb just to
find me to deliver her mother's last
words and the poor girls not even Undead
heavens I never asked her to do that
he came here seeking adventure and
that's quite a pure motive really
compared to others that grip those in
Lordran his ability to progress and
explore should keep him from hollowing
just as long as obstacles can be
overcome and adventure be had however
I've run flat up against a wall or a
gate I should say the thing just won't
budge no matter how long I wait and Oh
have I waited by my knighthood I'm
ashamed to ask but can you spare a few
scraps of moss this is quite a fix we'll
need another three no maybe five bodies
hmm quite a fix
the name Sigma means victory and that is
what you take from him the gates the old
folk was that your doing not be worn
gallantry entails great risks next time
give me a chance to come up with a plan
well our fates do seem entwined don't
they
perhaps this too is the will of Lord
Gwyn as you save Sigma you may well be
draining his belief in himself leading
him to take one final stand
those monsters making life difficult for
you you need not be ashamed we're all in
the same boat you know I really have run
up quite a debt to you perhaps the time
has come it's a suicide mission to repay
his friend but you take that victory
from him as well and now I go don't be
Flo if you allow siegmeyer to sacrifice
himself here while you escape then he
will Hollow but with his honor intact
the only way for him to survive here as
if you save his life again but no didn't
you get away well you saved me once
again oh thank goodness
I'm exhausted so this is the last time
you'll see Sigma alive
my father he went on his final adventure
don't worry that's just the way he is
undead or know sort of reassuring really
if he goes Hollow I'll just have to kill
him again
the name Sieglinde means gentle battle
here she's simply jesting that she'll
always be there to rein him in even if
the worst happens and it's a joke in
poor taste for it comes true in the end
yeah now I see you were one of the bad
ones then there's only one thing to do
with you right dear little Boone and so
your friend Sikma meets his end in ash
lake he goes to join his wife in death
and there's nothing you can do to stop
it
[Music]
of course it's not over towards the end
when the world has almost burned to ash
ash itself will rise to inherit it these
are the uncondensed ed they're commanded
to rise as a last resort to bring the
fleeing lords of cinder back to their
thrones and it seems after secrets
hollowing one of C Glenn's line
attempted to link the fire the named
secret means Guardian or defender no
should have waited and he has see
Glenn's strength of purpose
we unhindered must put our duties first
and sigmaz disarming good nature but for
the moment we have a toast to make to
your vera my sword and our victory
together long may the sunshine
[Laughter]
before he was unconditionally your a
Lord unloved by his people he was a
giant who sacrificed everything but
brought doom down upon them all the same
so to siegward his dear friend he
entrusted the only blade capable of
felling him in return for a promise one
day I will link the fire and if the Bell
Tolls for me I may not have it in me to
return so kill me if I ever betray that
promise
perhaps you're impressed upon him the
importance of this role for secret to
must have attempted to link the fire how
else could he have become unconditioned
once did for her father secret does form
it seems I am in your debt
once again my facts I could have not
kept my promise without your now for a
final toast to your vana and my old
friend you're wrong may the Sun Shine
[Music]
[Laughter]
with his duty fulfilled secret succumbs
to his wounds and sigmaz bloodline ends
in glory in an adventure for the ages
[Music]
we have a new patreon merch but I'll
talk about that in a second first can
you believe that the original siegmeyer
prepared to cry was released back in
2012 did you watch it when it came out
all the way back then it's thanks to you
guys that I've been able to keep
refining my craft so thank you back then
I was able to start focusing on this
full time because of patreon and now I'd
like to announce a new patreon tier that
gets you something in return if you join
the collector tier and then you pledge
for three months consecutively you'll
automatically have this poster shipped
to your address it's a design of a
golden Valkyrie and it's somewhat
inspired by olden ring and it's designed
by C bot who created most of the
incredible merch on this channel so this
is a very very exclusive product
especially considering patreon only let
me set $30 as the minimum for this
product so only the most dedicated
patrons will want this and that's fine I
just wanted to let you know that it
exists and bleh you know that I
appreciate you all whether you're a
patron or just a viewer so thank you for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you